[Music]
so um
anybody been to a funeral lately
i don't want to that's so sad
catholic uh
funeral that was all
like a year and a half and ago yeah was
it was it was it open casket yeah it was
what happened so imagine the situation
right
you're
i don't know
it's your mom right oh come on don't
bring her into this i'm pathetic your
mom passed away like that dude thanks
bart yeah continue
continue with this great scenario i said
hypothetically right so you go to your
your mom's open casket funeral okay and
you go over to the casket
titties out
no no oh my mom got nice titties yeah
dude have you seen them let me tell you
because you were going
[Laughter]
was it ready for titties out no i just
this is
fakies it works lying down yes
point is i thought that's what you're
saying my bad you go to your mom's
funeral you look in the casket and it's
not your mom it's a random person
wearing all your mom's clothes what
everything little stand-in
that what that's a horror movie then do
you have a hope that your mom is still
alive i would
did they swap the person at the morgue
they accidentally put the wrong body in
the castle damn i thought this was gonna
be a kid's movie for a second like bar
thought
my mom's alive
can you imagine the movie starts at a
funeral well then whose mom's sister is
my mom what the [ __ ] about the other
dead nobody's listening yeah whatever
it's your mom kid and then you're like
your best friend or your dog will help
you on the mission because they're the
only one that believes you
and your your dog smells the the the
fake mom he's like
dude this is a great movie we should
look at this right now bart came up with
the [ __ ] kids movie i just i just
keep going
yeah yeah well then they go on it they
gotta get a flashlight go to the
graveyard in the middle of the night and
they're using the dog to smell to find
it becomes a reverse scavenger hut to
see where the bomb really like rescue
mom and there's a bunch of clues
everywhere and then they find out that
mom was actually a spy so she had to
fake her death to save her kids and
surfer bad guys were like what dude we
got to get these kids
on the kids trail
[ __ ] three ninjas
dude oh
where'd these kids come from man they
got high training huh dude
what why did why was it surf or bad guys
i don't know it's always surfer that's
that's who were the real bad guys back
there in real life you know why because
they're the only bad guys i can get beat
up by three kids yeah they gotta be
bumbling idiots genuinely
why was there always like a duel like
two stupid asses
every every even like in home alone it
was two dumbasses
yeah well yeah harry wasn't that dumb
that's true yeah well the the wet
bandits that's what marv martin was a
dumb [ __ ]
that screwed everything up
terry had a plan dude it was like pinky
in the brain
[Laughter]
uh horace and jasper from 101 dalmatians
that was the other two idiot you
remember the name wow
that's a deep cut you're an imdb
you don't even have kids and you
remember that [ __ ] dumb and dumber
you're an imdb kind of guy huh
any goofs in that movie or
where'd you get that hat were you
wearing it the whole time yeah
thanks anthony he doesn't pay attention
to me this guy i walked in with his
[ __ ] eye i said how do you win this
hat no i'll kiss you on the mouth with
this hat i hit you with the bill of the
house through my mouth yeah you [ __ ]
jesus back to the non-hypothetical two
sisters from north carolina said that
they made a starting startling discovery
when they found a stranger's body inside
the casket that was supposed to contain
their mother was it a guy
that would have been well they did say
there's no similarity in the person one
of the sisters says in an interview the
size was way off uh when the first
person those were all tight on her she
was swimming in the clothes because she
was so small compared to my mother
pretty their mom's a fat asian lady and
then it was like some white grandma
she was in like a kimono or something
yeah there's also an ethnic problem with
it as well yeah there could be
[ __ ] a rice paddy hat on and they were
like yo this is [ __ ] cultural
appropriation like molina fans
another white another white person
taking an asian role
colonel striker like reversed last
samurai
there are two separate shitty jokes
going on at the same time it's just
funny to think she has martial arts
weaponry in the casket
that's what that was our scenario
there's no way she mastered the tonfas
that's how they figured it out he fans
and [ __ ] because that's part of our
culture okay
jesus oh my god that's how far it had to
go for them to know
hold on everything else checks out this
is north carolina why is that white lady
in there
cynthia rothrock
the scissors claim that uh that hundreds
funeral home in a a husky which is about
120 miles northeast of raleigh uh failed
to acknowledge the issue and even deny
that the person
that's a bad debate double down
dude that's your mother it's your mommy
dumb [ __ ] that's not my mom
that's your mom i'm dead bro stupid she
looks different when there's dead oh no
the dead version it's called rigo mortis
they look different dude
rigo
they got your mom on rico mortis dude
rico
look it's common okay asians turn into
white grandmas when they die it just
happens everyone knows it this is just a
part of metamorphosis
the pruning of a dead person go check
the inside of the great wall of china
it's a bunch of buried white people
so stupid
it actually goes in checks it'd be way
funnier if it was a black family and
then there was a white light in the
castle that would be ultimate like
that's a swisher
i think it's only funny right now
because we're talking about asians
saying it's like black but it's funny to
hear like careful boys the people that
that work at this mortuary they're like
no no that's her dude trying to check
come on look at the clothes
look at the clothes
it's your casket it's your clothes two
out of three things are correct yeah
come on dude that's your mom oh you
gotta sell it you gotta is this the
casket that you bought yes are those
your mother's pearls yes
and her outfit she loved that one then
it's three out of three there you go
must be your mother girl
is that her eskrama
that are you buried with all these
[ __ ] martial arts
is that her trisectional staff
what's her cali stick is that her bow
tri-sectional that's her monk spade
is that her [ __ ] thomas
the one that says cutlery yeah and
there's [ __ ] there's 20 klingon
how do those stores stay open yo i don't
know but as a kid i always walked in to
look at them you know what they make
their money off of i think they're
sharpening knives you know i think
that's where they make their money off
no is that your tanto they don't make it
that's a front
guys like me i've never seen him keeping
them or like the patio worlds over there
like really i'm the one that's buying
all that [ __ ]
i'm the one keeping them in business bro
these weapons are seven years old though
where's the new purchases
you want to be buried with all these how
did you support them during covet
i just kept buying it
you kept buying old ones i guess
holy [ __ ] some other guy like me [ __ ]
bought him that's what happened
i [ __ ] loved walking in the cutlery
stores like that nobody would ever buy
anything in there they would just look
around like i remember all the movie
replica swords and just nerding out on
stupid blade swords i was like
yeah
oh you guys you guys used to go to the
uh mexican swami ones right that they
would sell hella illegal knives like
brass knuckles and switch plates
college you want to talk about the
parking lot there was a cypress college
parking lot one yeah the swami i didn't
know everything across from cypress high
school
and they sold like weapons there yeah
there was like two booster balls that
always had like [ __ ] like the new
swords from the hobbit and [ __ ] like
that dude aloha stadium in hawaii they
have a cool swap meet and they always
have the coolest [ __ ] knives over
there dude they have brass knuckles with
blades on them and [ __ ] they have a
wolverine claw and they're like yeah you
put in your chat songs you're like you
put in your [ __ ] uh your your check
bag you can take it that's true i
brought brad's knuckles from thailand
that way
you got it through the airport yeah and
i was only 14. check the luggage dude i
got cloud sword from final fantasy vii
through is no problem
wait how big was this but brass knuckles
are you talking about i got the og-1
from the cutlery store
you for real have clouds
sword yeah you still have it yeah is
that displayed somewhere yeah i got over
my [ __ ] bed you [ __ ] weirdos
i'm talking about sneaking that thing
through customs it'd be absurd
[Laughter]
over his head
that thing's massive it's crazy that's
old point is that their wedding do they
head out in front of their way i
wouldn't be surprised i mean like you
could you could bring what cellos and
[ __ ] snowboards and
whole mountain bikes yeah so can't bring
[ __ ] clouds
it's rare that people are trying to kill
somebody with a cello though i think you
shouldn't be able to bring cloud sword
through personally [ __ ] display of
things you can't break
specifically
i think a cello makes more sense
you're comparing a cello
[Laughter]
you can you can check in guns
yeah you can
[Music]